the supposed mightiest demigod of eldon
ring is one of the most imposing
characters and boss fights in the game
but surprisingly a lot of his background
and lore are actually pretty easily
accessible and explained so in this
video i want to look at the lore and
background of the mighty red mained
warrior but also present an explanation
of his actions that i think has yet to
receive much attention today we enter
the great festival to fight overcome and
understand the demigod general
starscourge radan
because radon has some lore that is more
well known such as his doting over his
horse leonard i won't necessarily be
exploring every single in-game reference
as meticulously in this video though i
will still be doing my best to present
the lion's share of his lore and
background i'll supplement the more
relaxed lore dive by spending more time
speculating on his motivations and where
we find him in the events of the game
this will be informed by the lore but
it's one of the areas where no
conclusive answer is given so it leaves
room for speaking on what seems likely
as opposed to what is certain
starting at the beginning radon is the
son of ratagan and ranala brother to
ronnie and reichard
he attained the status of demigod's
stepchild when radagon left ranala and
became the second elden lord through his
union with queen america
we learn that radon took pride in his
father from his redmayne helms
description which reads radon inherited
the furious flaming red hair of his
father ratagon and is fond of its heroic
implications i was born a champion's cub
now i am the lord of the battlefields
lion the last line references radon's
other source of inspiration the warrior
king godfrey first elden lord being the
first elden lord and the one who fought
in the wars of the erd tree godfrey was
a warrior through and through so much so
that his eyes dulled when he had
vanquished his last worthy enemy
the warrior lord even had to take the
beast regent sirosh on his back to quell
his lust for battle ratagon and his
championship may have found fondness in
radon but it is the first elden lord who
truly enthralled him as we learn from
the rest of radon's armor which sports a
golden lion the golden lion is said to
symbolize godfrey the first elden lord
and his beast regent sirosh from his
youngest years radon was naturally
captivated by the lord of the
battlefield
we see the drives of battle and war that
make up much of the character of godfrey
to be very present in radon as well he
is known as the mightiest of the
demigods from such sources as jiren and
the star scourge heirloom one of his
most prolific titles found in a variety
of places is that of general and he led
a host of mighty and extremely dedicated
soldiers in the red mains they were all
reputed to be masterful warriors and it
was popularly said that the red mains
knew no weakness
these themes of war and pride and combat
are central to understanding radon and
we will see them again later but first i
must note that they are not all that
make him up he is after all also son to
ranala the carrion queen
so it's unsurprising that he also
developed an affinity for sorceries
namely those related to space we learn
from his remembrance what is at this
point one of the most famous tidbits of
eldon ring lore
the red lion general wielded
gravitational powers which he learned in
celia during his younger days also he
would never have to abandon his beloved
but scrawny steed these powers of
gravitation are on full display in
radon's boss fight both to attack the
player but also to move around his
scrawny steed who we know from zuli the
witch to be named leonard pradhan is
obviously quite large so without the
gravitational magic he would have to
have left the horse he probably grew up
with more on radon's large size can be
found in my ratagon video so here we get
a bit of personal character development
for radon in his love for his horse
helping to flesh him out a bit as a real
person
these powers also gave an opportunity
for radon to learn under one more master
an alabaster lord we learn from
sorceries like roxling and gravity well
that described themselves as a
gravitational technique studied by the
young radon his master was an alabaster
lord with skin of stone
this connection to an alabaster lord
lines up with what we will see as one of
radon's greatest feats but to understand
the connection we must first learn what
the alabaster lords are from their sword
we read that they are a race of ancients
with skin of stone who are said to have
risen to life when a meteor struck long
ago the alabaster are a race that either
came from or are associated with the
stars and these stars are where we turn
to see the next chapter of regan's story
the gravitational powers might have
started as a way to stay with his horse
but they soon became something much
greater for radon a way to prove his
might and earn renown throughout the
lands between
it is because of these that he gained
the moniker starscourge and the heirloom
of the same name tells the story the
mightiest hero of the demigods
confronted the falling stars alone and
thus did he crush them his conquest
sealing the very fate of the stars
we also see the tale relayed in a swords
monument in caled which states
the star scourge conflict where don
alone holds celia secure and stands tall
to shatter the stars
this phrases radon as being somewhat of
a defender of celia perhaps the stars
spelled doomed to the town where radon
studied maybe they carried with them a
threat such as more beans like the
alabaster lords or estelle and the
falling star beasts
would these supposed beings bring some
form of danger it's hard to say
or maybe there was some other reason
entirely to halt the stars we will look
at some of these more potential options
later in any case this is a pivotal
moment in radon's story and in situating
the world of the lands between as we
find them in-game there is more to the
lore of radon his connection with minor
npcs his actions during and after the
shattering and his fight with melania
but the rest of these seem much more
contingent to me and not as essential to
radon's story
to briefly cover them they first show
how radon may have laid siege to the
capital and yes i think it's reasonable
to read the cinematics opening slide as
morgot and radon as every other slide
features prominent demigods or other
prominent characters associated with
them so why would this slide just have
morgot be attacking a complete random or
a soldier that looks so much like
pradhan
later we see radon and melania the often
talked about fight where radon waits for
melania to equip her prosthetic before
picking up his own weapons obviously
displaying his desire for a fair
honorable fight
his theme of gallantry in battle is once
again apparent wanting proper combat
itself more than any end that that
combat could serve as a means to
this is the fight which left caled
festering in rot and radon mindless and
infected all sense having left him which
is the state we find him in game
with that covered i don't think any of
this is as important as the conquest of
the stars which is saying something
because we don't know that much about
what this key moment even means there is
very little explanation of the conflict
and we as players are left to guess why
radon did this and what doing this meant
we do know that this is an important
event because one it is what gave radon
his most impactful title star scourge
two it is something he continued to do
even through the loss of his mind the
stars remained held until his death and
three because it held effect for the
fates of other characters in the lands
between
we can learn about this connection from
the witch selen who explains that the
stars alter the fate of the karyan royal
family
and the fate of your mistress rani
but long ago general radhan challenged
the swirling constellations
and in a crushing victory arrested their
cycles
now he is the force that repulses the
stars
if general radan were to die
the stars would resume their movement
and so too would rani's destiny
when we defeat radon the stars are set
free to move again and with them the
fate of those tied to them the
blacksmith eg has some explanatory
dialogue you've defeated general radan
unlocking the stars
the general was blighted by scarlet rot
and driven to madness
but not long ago he was hailed as the
mightiest demigod of them all
there is no parallel to your achievement
no to lady rani's acute judgment of
character
thanks to you
lady rani's fate once again stirs
and the path to nokron has opened
descend underground
where the fallen star struck klimgrave
and make it yours
the precious treasure
of nokron
so radon was holding not only the stars
but the fate of his sister ronnie in
stasis here is where i wish to offer my
own theory we don't know for certain why
radon holds the stars back so we are
left to speculate with the little
information we have it seems reasonable
to me to think that radon could be
interpreted as acting on ronnie's side
here to make the case we know ronnie
employed the help of her other brother
reichard in her plotting we read from
the blasphemous claw the item that lets
us parry malakath and deflect the power
of the black blade that on the night of
the dire plot ronnie rewarded preda
reichard with these traces should the
coming trespass one day transpire they
would serve as a last resort foil
allowing riker to challenge malaketh the
black blade the black beast of destined
death so maybe ronnie also employed the
help of her other brother radon
as ronnie was an emperian she was
slaughtered to be a potential successor
to queen america we know the other two
empirians melania and mikala were both
cursed from birth so maybe the greater
will saw ronnie as the favorite empyrean
if radon's actions of holding back the
stars halted the progression of ronnie's
fate maybe that also meant that she
couldn't progress to godhood and succeed
america as long as the stars were in
stasis this stalling could let ronnie
prepare her plan in peace
we learn from radon's star scourge
greatsword that he earned considerable
renown as the star scourge in his youth
so this would mean that either ronnie
had this plan in place from when radon
was young or it was an unintentional
byproduct that radon didn't explicitly
intend to help ronnie in her plan but it
ended up that way
we could also look at the holding back
the stars from the point of view of
radon himself obviously it earned him
renown but it also should have stalled
his own fate radon was a carrion too so
his fate was subject to the stars
maybe holding them back would mean he
could gain renown and fight in battle
without having to worry about death or
an undesirable progression of his own
fate before he felt he was ready or had
proven his battle-worthiness
both of these theories could tie into
the radon we see in game because he has
lost his mind he is unable to choose to
release the stars for ronnie this means
that he has to die for her plan to
progress
if he hadn't been infected with rot
perhaps ronnie would have been able to
tell or ask radon to release the stars
to allow her to move forward with her
plan no sibling murder needed
the rot also prevents radon from moving
forward with his own fate and plans his
armies are scattered and plagued radon
has no wit to reassemble them or to
continue to wage battle but it seems he
cannot die either by stalling the stars
and losing his ability to choose to free
them radon has put himself in a feedback
loop that seems impossible to break the
stars prevent his fate from progressing
and the rot prevents him from releasing
the stars so he is forever cursed to sit
in the sands gorging on the bodies of
friend and foe alike
perhaps the stalling of the stars even
takes away his ability to progress to
death until of course someone even
mightier comes along like the tarnished
would the rot have killed radon if not
for the stars being held up would his
great rune burning with fire have
resisted the rot and kept him alive in
any case or is all of this metaphorical
holding of fate not really applicable
was the halted fate of ronnie really
just because the physical star that
radon held back would open up the path
to nokron and if he let it go it would
allow rani's plan to progress because
nokron would simply now be physically
accessible unfortunately we can't say
for certain i think some blend of these
themes presented makes sense as does the
idea that radon could have been helping
ronnie since such help did not seem to
get in the way of his own yearning for
battle or glory but either way we are
left in this sea of speculation
ronnie doesn't seem malicious to her
siblings and radon seemed to have
war-minded but fair intentions the
shattering after all did offer new
opportunities for war as all the great
wars had already been ended well except
for the war with the stars apparently
radon would have had a good deal of
motivation to go along with his sister's
plans since it offered him a pristine
opportunity for war that he wouldn't
have gotten otherwise but this is
speculation what we can say for certain
is that despite the mindless curse of
rot radon did hold onto one ideal
something which was with him since
childhood that guided his life of battle
learning and combat something that i
will say i think supports my theory
after we defeat radon in glorious
spectacle fighting amongst a host of
champions as the game clearly begs us to
do we can hear a concluding remark from
jaren the guest commander who served the
star scourge in combat and war
he sums it all up saying
at last
the war festival has ended
brave champion
you have our gratitude
the celebration was spectacular
general radar is surely pleased
festering with rot and crippled by
madness
all he wanted
was an honorable death
i hope you have all enjoyed the video
radon is a hot topic in eldon ring
discussions making it to the top of many
lists of favorite boss fights and
characters there is more to discuss
surrounding him but i wanted to cover
some of what i thought were the really
core aspects of his story that didn't
get as much focus in the discussions
i've seen if you did enjoy then
subscribe and stick around as i will be
continuing to make more elden ring
videos lore and otherwise though i will
be on hiatus next month so videos might
be a bit more sporadic i plan to make a
few in advance so there isn't a total
content drought but the standard lore
vids will have some more space in
between them for just a bit well thanks
for watching follow me on twitter if you
haven't and peace